a sigh of relief from las vegas chapels
elvis is staying this comes after a
group that owns his brand wanted to put
a stop to all the elvis weddings but now
there's been a new deal he has not left
the building he's not left any of the
buildings he's all throughout the city
victoria saha at one of those a chapel
down on the strip with a look at how
chapels will now move forward
elvis is in the building and he's here
to stay so here's what happened
authentic brands group who owns elvis
brand was wanting to put a stop to this
iconic vegas wedding act but now they're
saying that they're willing to work with
the chapels it's hard to imagine getting
married in las vegas without elvis by
your side making your wedding even more
special
so when authentic brands group
threatened to put a stop to all chapel
weddings which included an elvis
impersonator many people were shook up
for me as an impersonator that would
pretty much end my career ron decker is
best known as elvis for the viva las
vegas chapel he has been acting as the
king of rock and roll for 27 years every
couple is calling us to think that their
wedding is going to be canceled because
now elvis isn't present anymore
after 45 years but there's good news abg
says they are now willing to partner up
with these chapels who use the elvis
brand hopefully we'll be able to work
out something with these people and it
won't be an exorbitant fee that we can't
afford we spoke with ben lahave a lawyer
who represents several chapels who have
been targeted by the abg group he says
earlier today abg told him they will
allow elvis impersonators in chapels
only if they pay a fee of hundreds of
dollars per chapel per year
we're feeling elated now this is a
period of weeks of being extremely
worried and concerned there are vegas
wedding chapels that seem to live almost
entirely on
elvis weddings and many people were very
very frightened get married with me
elvis thank you very much the logistics
of this agreement is still being worked
out but abg did say it was never their
intention to shut down the elvis chapels
we do have their full statement up on
our website for now looks like elvis is
staying in the building victoria zaha
live local now